ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman so earlier this week just by
virtue of some clips we were looking at
i ended up talking a little bit about
areas where the right just crushes the
left on
activism now i use the term activism
loosely because a lot of what the right
is doing is not really activism it's
sort of demonization
and uh uh it's really sort of a
different animal but to the extent that
the right is able to get
organized in certain ways they crush the
left and that includes at the local
level i've talked about
city councils i've talked about funding
the
sort of training of young conservatives
as they come out of college which the
left barely does i've talked about
school boards and so on and so forth
we now have an article that perfectly
illustrates this point
and it should really scare the left
because the left is terrible at this
type of stuff
and it's allowing the right to just do
it and to win
on a lot of these increasingly cultural
issues which is the the battle they've
chosen to fight
understand that the right has abandoned
fighting on policy they're fighting
cultural issues and this is a perfect
example take a look at this
article and truth out right wingers are
taking over
library boards to remove books
on racism now we hear this and we go oh
my god
this is so retrograde this is so
backwards we could be that this this
energy
that's been being spent on this could be
spent on
a thousand things that are more valuable
and i'm with you
but the point is they're not doing it
and we're not fighting them
as as efficiently and as uh
um uh intelligently as we could listen
to what the article says
um when joe makula decided to run for
the board of the niles maine
public library in niles illinois this
spring
a community member asked him how he
thought the library could better serve
the area's increasingly diverse
community
many were stunned by his response
instead of stocking up on books in seven
different languages he said
if we got people to assimilate and learn
english that would do more good that's
not policy that's a cultural issue
at the time of his candidacy makula was
a known person in niles having
previously led efforts to impose term
limits
on elected officials and stop the town
mayor from filling vacant trustee
positions but his interest in the
library
was new elizabeth lynch a member of the
save niles library coalition says she
doesn't know what provoked makula's
involvement but it became apparent his
goal
was to object to the library being a
community center
he also opposed to spending their
spending to repair the building's aging
roof
and upgrade the facility to better
bridge the digital divide
separating low-income residents from
their more affluent neighbors
but despite or perhaps because of his
political outlook makula
won the april election and now holds a
seat on the library board
it goes on to say since they're swearing
in on may 19th the new board has wasted
no time in imposing its agenda
their focus is to change the very nature
of the library they've slashed the
budget from 7.4 to 5.9 million
fired staff for reduced hours gone from
70 hours a week to 54 of being open
eliminated outreach to schools and
nursing homes and
and and they are starting to
actually weigh in on what books should
be allowed
some locales are making opposition to
critical race theory their core focus
but other locations are adding virulent
opposition to comprehensive
sex education lgbtqia plus acceptance in
a trio of concerns
they are fighting this from the ground
up
now is it disgusting of course it is
is it retrograde is it the stuff of
let's go back to the 50s and that these
right-wingers dream of
it's all of that and i'm against all of
it but much like i think
mitch mcconnell's actions have been
disgusting
can anyone say mitch mcconnell hasn't
been a hugely
effective republican from the standpoint
of uh pushing the right agenda
and blocking the democratic agenda
absolutely
and so unless we are going to get down
and fight them in these areas
we're just going to keep losing on a lot
of this stuff and we can go back to some
of the clips i played for you
um earlier this week here's the clip of
uh from cpac
this was an interview with a couple
people at cpac remember this is the
stuff i pointed out and i said
they are smart to fight at this level
pay
attention to their children and what
they say when they come home from school
don't criticize listen if there's things
that go against what they've been
teaching their children
then they need to go to a school board
meeting and they do
and they do is what we're learning we
need to read the books that our kids are
being forced to read
so that we can have an honest
conversation with them there's a way to
fight back
and the way to do it is use your words
and use your money
go to your schools don't send your kid
to an indoctrination camp
and they're doing it okay here's another
one this was just a random interview i
mean as far as we know sometimes these
are plants but as far as we know this
was a random interview with cpac
um and listen right away to what this
woman i believe from california says
sure sure what are you yeah i am from
california
and um i'm an activist and uh i believe
in what we're saying here about getting
involved and stuff
but i think we forget to mention that
how we're going to do that we need to
get back into the neighborhoods
we need to do in california right now we
are organizing
uh precincts and voter registration
we're not talking about voter
registration i i think that's
actually that's a great point i'm glad
you came up to us these people
understand it now am i saying the left
doesn't understand it no
i think the left probably does
understand it i think the left probably
does understand it but
they're crushing us on this stuff and so
i am restating
the school boards the library boards i
mean listen when you
think of a library this is so micro but
politics is local think of a library
the very people that
i'll i'll give you even a specific
example um
you walk around on a small town's main
street
and you see uh people uh panhandling
asking for money and uh the
conservatives say
this looks terrible and this affects
property values and many on the left say
the same thing
great okay well let's get these folks
jobs uh many of them don't have internet
access many of them
uh uh you would need internet access in
order to get a job so where can
you go and get internet access well you
can go to libraries i have a friend
who's a librarian who says we have lots
of folks that come in and they're
what they're doing on our computers with
free internet access is applying
to jobs so being able to do that would
get folks
off of the street which is what
conservatives claim to want
and it wouldn't get them off because of
welfare it would get them off because
they got a job great
but then the conservatives go in and
they say let's slash the library budgets
and let's make the computer room smaller
or eliminate them altogether or not
replace the computers or whatever the
case may be
so not only are they beating us on a lot
of this stuff
by beating us on it they continue to
perpetuate
their talking point which is look at all
this terrible stuff going on in the
panhandling and the democratic mayor
well it's not the democratic mayor maybe
it's that conservative library board
that is making it so that a lot of these
folks don't have a place to go and apply
for jobs it's a micro
example but it illustrates exactly what
we're up against
and um it's just you know that just
dropped right in after the conversation
we had on monday so let's
we've got to refocus on that and we'll
have more to say about it in the future
i have a story today about how sometimes
we can find
like a point of agreement with
right-wingers and
then very quickly see that point of
agreement
devolve into them having some of the
absolute worst political instincts i can
imagine where
the solutions we imagined to the points
of agreement
couldn't be more different and we've
been covering
the rising unrest in cuba cuba's covid
situation is rapidly devolving
into a public health chaos that we've
not seen
throughout the pandemic in cuba the
economy is further collapsing
inflation is starting to explode and
we're not talking about five percent
thanks to more internet access in cuba
the cuban people are now coordinating
and hitting the streets in protest
this is a complicated situation in which
i as an
anti-authoritarian left-winger
oppose the cuban regime i do not know
how anyone calling themselves
progressives could support a regime
that came to power with fidel castro in
1959
stayed in power he stayed in power for
49 years
until 2008 and then handed power to his
brother raul castro that's not democracy
it's also an authoritarian police state
with total control over
just about every aspect of people
people's lives so as an
anti-authoritarian progressive who's in
favor of democracy
uh northern european social democracy
etc i am against that
there's no way i could be for that and
also
many cuban americans oppose that regime
many of them are right wingers
but they oppose the regime often for
different reasons
the current mayor of miami is
cuban-american francis
suarez he's the son of the first
cuban-born mayor of miami
the current mayor's father javier suarez
was also the mayor of miami previously
and
um he went on uh francis suarez that is
went on fox news yesterday and was
talking about what's going on in cuba
and somehow he ends up with you know
maybe the u.s military
should bomb cuba what how could that
possibly be
an action that would improve what's
going on in cuba if what we want to do
is
uh help the cuban people so let's look
at the full clip and you'll see that
along with a long list of terrible
instincts
there's this idea of military action
okay let's listen a repressive
government
and a cruel u.s embargo they deserve
policies that empower them
and help them improve their lives do you
think that president biden looking at
this
situation will lift that embargo and do
you think that's what he should do
no i don't think the embargo is is cruel
at all and i think that the cuban people
are not asking for a lifting of the
embargo
okay so two two things already first of
all
the cuban embargo you know cruel or not
is completely hypocritical the cuban
embargo is based on the idea that the
united states disagrees with cuba's
system of government
i'm with you i disagree with it as well
i also disagree with saudi arabia's
system of government
and yet we continue that relationship
almost completely unquestioned even by
most of the democratic establishment so
again if we want to credibly say we want
to help the cuban people
the cuban embargo hasn't forced them to
change their system of government
for uh you know 60 years or whatever the
case is at this point in time 60 60
something years 62 years
um and it's just hurting the cuban
people number two
when suarez says the protests from the
cuban people aren't
against the embargo listen they may not
be
overtly against the embargo but much of
what
is leading cuba to be what it is right
now
is related to that embargo not all of it
part of it is the system of government
in cuba
and i vehemently and vehemently believe
that that has to change
but to say the protests have nothing to
do with the embargo
that that ignores context completely but
let's keep going
on the streets every single day talking
about the failure of the communist
regime
to provide for its people and i don't
understand why that's so difficult for
people to understand
so it can be both francis we can both
say
the authoritarian police state
anti-democratic regime that's been in
place since 1959
is unlikely to be great for the people
of cuba and that's true
and the american embargo also makes it
worse both things can be true then we
get into the military it has failed for
six decades and what should be being
contemplated right now
is a coalition a potential military
action
in cuba similar to what has happened in
both administrations in both republican
and democrat administrations
and republican with bush and panama they
depose noriega
and that country had peace military
action
military action i mean listen it's a
different debate
but one might argue you talk about
military action
if there's a real risk to the united
states or
our interests uh in cuba you know other
than guantanamo bay i don't know
exactly what interests we have uh
there's a national security threat
um cuba having uh
a large population that has almost
nothing and being oppressed by that
regime
military action come on it is not a
national security threat
the likes of which we would be talking
about military action whether that's
bombing
whether that's an assassination campaign
by a
covert arm of the military or whatever
this is
just the the the the epitome of
i'm against the cuban regime as an
anti-authoritarian
leftist francis suarez is against the
cuban regime
based on the vague idea of being against
communism and we're both against the
regime
but military action that's the last
thing that's on my mind
and it is just another example
of how even when we find points of
agreement
with some of these folks their solutions
are very much the wrong ones and this
has been a big thing with populism i've
said before one of the dangers of
populist rhetoric and falling for it
is that populist rhetoric from left
wingers and populist rhetoric from right
wingers sounds very similar and then you
get to the solutions
and man of the people tucker carlson is
saying well we need a solution because
soon black lives matter is going to take
your house and brown people coming in
are the problem
right uh the immigrants make the country
dirty as he has previously said
and that's the pernicious nature of that
rhetoric so let me know your thoughts
you can find me
on twitter at deepakman remember that
august 16th
is the 16th anniversary of the david
pakman show we are having a huge
membership blowout uh my lawyer
and accountant are beating down the
doors saying sir
don't do it don't do this don't you you
can't do it sir it's going to be too big
of a discount
sure sure exactly but we're doing it on
august 16th
and you can get on our newsletter by
signing up at davidpakman.com
uh hope you'll participate we'll be back
right after this
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back
ground news is one of the first things i
would use
to get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform
that lets you compare how outlets from
the left right and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how
sources with differing political biases
are covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spots stories that your side of the
political spectrum
may not have covered ground news can
help you build a well-crafted argument
for debating people you disagree with
or ground news can help you discover
something new
about your own perspective challenging
your own strongly held views on
political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the free ground news app today
by going to ground.news slash
pacman i would love it if you signed up
for a david pakman show membership at
joinpakman.com not only are you
supporting the show but you get
stuff including the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
and we do an extra show every day i
don't want to call it
the fun half like sam cedar does but
it's pretty fun
it's not bad and it's won some awards
awards we've created specifically to
award ourselves but certainly awards
nonetheless
sign up at joinpakman.com you can use
the coupon code better21
to get yourself a discount so we're
continuing to fight disinformation about
vaccines and it's it's really becoming a
game of whack-a-mole at this point
vaccination is the way out of the
pandemic
we are seeing a rapid rise in cases
cases up
69 percent in the united states since
the uh bottom
uh um a few weeks ago told you about
that yesterday or the day before
and one thing that really makes me sick
of the covet vaccine conspiracies
is that some of them so obviously don't
make sense and yet
they keep getting repeated they become
memetic and viral
the vaccine has metal and it magnetizes
you that was going around for a while in
fact
i told the story of my lyft driver in
miami i got to miami for vacation a
couple weeks ago
get into a car masked of course i was
wearing 12 masks and
a helmet and the lyft driver says oh no
no no i'm not getting vaccinated because
my mom
got the second dose and then her whole
body became magnetized
uh that's one another one is the vaccine
modifies your dna it's called an mrna
vaccine you inject it and then your dna
becomes modified it's almost like you
become some kind of hybrid being
the vaccine can give you the virus is
another one that was earlier on and one
that's been floating around for a little
bit now is that simply
being around vaccinated people could do
things to you
and the term that they've come up with
is shedding vaccine
sort of an analogous term to the concept
of shedding virus particles when you're
sick
here's one example this is deanna
lorraine deanna lorraine is a republican
conspiracy theorist
who ran for california's 12th
congressional district last year lost
the primary
she's explaining to some guy i don't
even know who this is
about how she was around vaccinated
people
and uh her period got all messed up take
a listen to this
when i took a little trip last month i
was telling you about with a couple of
my
liberal uh friends last uh last month
for a weekend we were in close quarters
i
uh they had all been vaccinated and i'm
the only one that hadn't been vaccinated
already a red flag right okay good and
it's a mistake that i'll never
make again in my i wish she was saying
the mistake was not being vaccinated but
that's not where she's going with this
life but i missed my period and
yeah again sorry earmuffs but i missed
my period and i haven't received it
since
i'm freaking out a little bit i'm scared
because could i be infertile now
so the first question is if you're that
freaked out don't you call a doctor
right like why are you reporting it to
stu peters maybe is this guy's name
um haven't you all why wouldn't you
already have asked your doctor about it
vaccine shedding is real it's causing
lots of different side effects including
missed periods in women
infertility early menopause and women in
their 30s
and now i've experienced it firsthand
and i need to protect myself i'm no
longer going to be around vaccinated
women
because i need to care about my
fertility and i can you imagine so
there's a couple there's a few things
there
first of all where to even start
so no no evidence of early menopause
related to the vaccine
no evidence of infertility related to
the vaccine but there's really two parts
here
first is the vaccine causing
missed periods if you get the vaccine
versus whether you could miss a period
from being
near someone who has been vaccinated
let's do the latter first
there is no way to be affected by people
around you being vaccinated other than
you will be less likely to get the virus
and you will be less likely to end up in
the hospital
and you will be less likely to die
thanks to people around you being
vaccinated
if you were sick with covid your body
can release virus particles as you cough
etc so you can be
you're sick you can be shedding the
virus that's true
unless you are vaccinated with a vaccine
that contains live
virus which the coveted vaccines do not
your body can't shed
vaccine particles or virus particles
whatever it is that you call them
there's no physiological mechanism for
it to happen
with the vaccines that are being used in
the united states um
vincent vendito who's an assistant
professor of pharmaceutical sciences
says quote it is possible to have viral
shedding after a vaccine
but that requires a vaccine with a
live virus to be used as the basis for
the vaccine
that is not the basis of the covet
vaccines used in the united states
the only way for this to potentially
happen is to have
a live attenuated vaccine it has a
weakened version
of the germ that causes the disease none
of our coveted vaccines in the u.s
do that with the live virus now in terms
of vaccines affecting the periods of
women who get vaccinated
women's periods and the immune system
are very very much connected
as a woman is about to ovulate her
immune system
ramps itself up to prevent any
infectious agents from maybe interfering
with the fertilization
and implantation of an egg so that you
can successfully start a pregnancy this
is like reproductive science
once the egg is fertilized and implants
the immune system
dampens to accept the pregnancy the
uterus has immune cells those can be
affected by hormonal changes the immune
system and cortisol the stress hormone
are related and periods respond very
strongly to cortisol levels so
the long and short of that is it's being
studied
there are anecdotal reports of a late
period after the second dose in
some women we don't yet know whether
it's related to the vaccine
it's conceivable that the vaccine might
impact
one or two period the timing of one or
two periods following the second dose
because your immune system is hard at
work developing immunity to the virus
and or due to the elevated cortisol
levels there's no evidence of an impact
on fertility
there's no evidence of a long-term
effect and remember
this woman wasn't even vaccinated
herself she's claiming
just by being near vaccinated people
she believes her menstruation was
affected so this is
really wild stuff and these are sticky
ideas that are not going away one of the
hallmarks
of pseudo-intellectualism is to say
things
that are really simple or overtly
counter-intuitive
and to pretend that they're profound or
that they give some unique insight
something no one else is willing to say
maybe when in reality they're just wrong
now you might be saying david what are
you talking about i have an example for
you right here
um there is a guy who some might be
familiar with his name is tai
smith he's a conservative black father
who's being
popularized by right-wing media as a
conservative black father
who is willing to tell the truth about
race related issues and the truth is he
sees it is
u.s isn't racist hasn't been racist and
now he even says
slavery wasn't racist in the united
states
let's just uh get right into it yeah
because they're
they're very invested in this whole idea
that the
nation was founded on the idea of
systemic racism that it's built into
every single institution in america even
in the military
folks are worried that this is something
that they need to address within the
military and we just did a story about
how the navy is under prepared right now
but they're spending a heck of a lot of
time on this what do you think about
that
it's absolutely absurd because nobody
really wants to get the real history of
it the brain
america was not founded on racism don't
get me wrong yeah there was slavery
going on but slavery itself was not
initially a racist thing it never
slavery itself was not
initially a racist thing and right
wingers watching fox
all of a sudden this guy appears and
they say whoa hold on a second
um it's fox so i trust it implicitly
and here's a black guy saying not only
was this
nation not racist in its in its
foundation but
even slavery wasn't racist and this
guy's black
so now i'm absolved of having to
actually deal with
any racial inequity or whatever i don't
have to feel guilty about anything
as if that's actually the point right um
this is crazy
this is let's listen to a little bit
more it was about race initially
so to sit there and take it like america
was founded on racism it's a complete
lie yeah there was slavery going on but
slavery was going on
in all the world it never was a race
thing so why are we making it a race
thing now
so there's a bunch of stuff there that
we can address all right
um the one of the
things he says is sort of a red herring
right now it is true
that there were african slaves in places
other than the united states he says
slavery was going on all over the world
it's true only about four to six percent
of african slaves that were taken from
africa
came to the united states the other 94
to 96 percent
went to other places sometimes even
within africa they were enslaved
that doesn't change whether slavery in
the united states was racist
i hope that you realize that that's a
complete and total red herring
now sometimes what you will hear is
slavery in the u.s wasn't racist
because there were irish people also
enslaved
in colonial america early on
that's also not true large numbers of
indentured servants
did come to the united states from
ireland and in fact
went to numerous british colonies
including those in north america
they they chose to do it the conditions
were absolutely terrible
indentured servitude has elements of
slavery including that
you're you're bound to the the whoever
you're working for for a period of time
but it's not actually slavery it's
terrible but indentured servitude
is not chattel slavery so that's another
argument that they will
sometimes make and then to even say that
there it wasn't racist in that
i don't even know what they mean do they
mean it just so happened
that they were bringing people from
africa all of whom were black
um i don't know how you argue that
that's not racist in its in its
implementation
and if you you can even look at things
written at the time about slavery
one reason that you will find written
about why why is it african slaves that
are brought to the u.s
one reason is they were chosen for their
dark skin so they they could work out
in the sun all day and i guess you know
be less susceptible to
uh to to to sun damage so how is that
not race based
and uh it's it's a very weak argument
but the question that you really have to
uh kind of ask is what
um political point is propped up by
arguing that it wasn't actually about
race
who does it benefit politically it
benefits those
who want to do nothing right now about
inequalities that exist along racial
lines
to be able to say those inequalities are
not the result
of any historical racial oppression or
discrimination
as many people see it absolves them of
really having to figure out
or do anything about the circumstances
of racial inequality
in which the united states finds itself
today which are of course much improved
compared to what they were
they are not as bad as in many other
countries as i've said before
but they still exist and so that's the
political point that's the reason why
this is a narrative if you
if you can even gaslight people into
thinking
and the enslavement of african slaves
wasn't race-based or racist you can
essentially convince people of anything
and that's exactly what they're trying
to do here we'll have more about this on
our instagram
and i'd be curious to hear your thoughts
about it um uh instagram
uh on instagram we are david pakman show
all one word
and if you want to see my eggplant on
instagram that's at david.pakman i've
got
two eggplants now growing in the
backyard it's really a sight to see
follow me there we'll take a quick break
and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular
show with no commercials you also get
access to our entire archive of every
episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program rachel bittikoffer who's an
election forecaster and analyst host of
the podcast the election whisperer
founder of strike pack and i think
rachel someone who is increasingly
concerned about what 2022 is looking
like for democrats am i right
yeah i mean you know if you're a trained
political scientist like i am
and your area of expertise happens to be
campaigns and elections voter behavior
there is no there's few uh trends in
that kind of research
that is as adamant as robust
as continuous as the midterm effect so
you know even before i mean literally as
a
byte was walking across the stage and
getting inaugurated
the fundamentals of this cycle are are
against the democrats so you know given
what happened
in 2020 not only where they structurally
had this huge fundamentals advantage
but then the events of 2020 could not
have set up
a challenger uh trying to oust an
incumbent
better than joe biden in that fight
right seeing
seeing the democrats unable to
capitalize on that
down ballot and not just because it's
something that happens right like
it's something you have to make the
conditions for and they did not
do that right uh we have a lot of
problems in our in the way our system uh
infrastructure for electioneering is
uh all the way from organizational to
tactics to strategy
that make it distinct from the
republican universe and so those two
things combined
should have everybody concerned so let's
start with like the top level
and then work to the specifics of this
next election
there's this general idea that you have
the control of the white house switch
in one election and then in that next
midterm
the party that takes control of the
house uh i'm sorry that takes control of
the white house
doesn't do well in the house often
losing now it doesn't always happen but
it
it happens frequently what is there on
top of that structural thing
that may be specific to the current
slate of democrats and republicans that
concerns you for 22.
yeah i mean here let me just say in
terms of in terms of what you just said
about you know it doesn't always happen
but it happens frequently let me be very
very clear
the last 40 midterm cycles in 38 of them
right party suffered midterm loss
in the hyper-polarized polarized era
which is a
you know if you think about soil periods
or anthropology or something like that
we're living in a very distinct behavior
pattern time period of hyper
partisanship and polarization
in that era we have seen these large
mid-term effects not that we've never
seen large ones in history
but we're seeing them kind of become the
staple and of course that is because we
have this
uh very very distinct um you know
two-party coalition
set up right now you know we didn't
always have these two parties
took a long time for them to
institutionalize and now they have these
very institutionalized
voting mates uh that are ideologically
homogeneous
that are uh you know at least especially
the republican um format
very um demographically homogeneous and
therefore you don't have like a midterm
swing because people are like ah
you know i tried a i've tried coke and
i'm like i haven't tried pepsi
right that's not so much of what's
happening there is always some voters
moving choice
um you know who are going from a coke to
pepsi
but what's really power in these large
midterms
is that the demographic composition of
the electorate is
switching a lot of that switch by the
way david isn't coming from the right
okay it comes from
us um participating and pulling back
right um and you know that's that's what
i'm trying to head off yeah let's talk
about that a little
bit i a couple weeks ago i said you know
um
we had a situation like you like you're
pointing out 2020
was just ripe for joe biden to to
oust an incumbent everything went wrong
under trump and then on top of that
you had this disastrous pandemic
response and still
while the popular vote margin was big um
it came down to relatively
300 000 votes in a few states the same
way that it did in 2016 2016 could have
gone hillary 2020 could have gone trump
right
i imagine that with a democrat
in the white house maybe now this is
more a 24 conversation than 22
i don't think that democrats will be as
motivated
to re-elect joe biden or if it's kamala
harris and biden goes one term
and so i worry that republicans will be
reinvigorated by saying let's get trump
back in
and that's a real concern to me is that
concern warranted in your mind
that should make you guys all stay up at
night like it does me i mean here i am
days away out from uh
appendectomy and i'm doing the show
today because it's so
urgent that i i tell as many people as
possible and turn
as many people as possible onto it the
solution
yeah it's not like okay we have this
problem and
you're getting a lot of oxygen about
that in the media but the solution is
is as equally i mean it's more important
right and the solution of course
if we can implement it here isn't so
much it isn't just about having the
policy power
um it is about staving off potentially
democratic collapse so
you know it's just so critical that
people understand
on that other side they think they're
the good guys yeah okay they think we're
the bad guys because they're fed
all of this um hyper partisan you know
red meat
it's constant crisis and threat right
and so what the things that they're
doing over there to dismantle democracy
they would tell you are in defense of it
and they believe that and we all know
objectively
that that's not true we and if we get
confused we can look at international
audiences to find out
are we doing groupthink or are we
actually right you know
and and it's and it's absolutely the
case that they
they are going to be on fire to put
donald trump back in that white house
they are going to be on fire to flip
congress as
we were when we felt the threat of their
in-party power
right and um you know the democrats hope
is that oh if biden's relatively
personally popular if we do a couple of
these big packages
things will just be fine and that's you
know that was not an unreasonable hope
in 1990
or maybe even in the early 2000s but
yeah not now
because we have a distinct behavior in
the electorate
as you just pointed out as show as
donald trump's term
in officer
was you know everything on hyper um
drive but also
different too because it wasn't abstract
stuff that we care about
it was pandemic is coming to kill you
your family take all your stuff
you know kill your um your personal
wealth everything right
and if you still end up with the same
contest i told you you would end up with
yeah 16 months before the election
almost to the letter i said this is
exactly how 2020 will play out
that means something's really wrong with
your political system because
when a giant stimulus comes in like that
there should be reaction right like the
thing that we should have seen in a
healthy
if if politics didn't need to change
from the 80s and the 90s
then we wouldn't have seen a um you know
repeat of 2016 and not in 1980
reagan carter shellacking right now
along those lines i mean when you talk
about
policy and all these different things
the republican party
is not really a party of policy anymore
it's communism and socialism are going
to take over
mitch mcconnell is great because he
stops democrats from doing things
uh critical race theory etc so how do
you run against that how do you
if you're how do what do democrats need
to do right that's the frustrating part
is
it's really easy to run against that but
not if you're
tinkering in the in the lead and the
limbs of the tree okay
like our their system is built like that
like they've built
and michael steele is like you know me
and him and i are like tandem
um he was on tv last night on on brian
williams show
yeah trying to explain to people look
this is a like
we go in there and we we just decimate
your brand like we
the reason they don't need policy or uh
achievements and i tweeted about this
last night
is that it's not to to the electorate
that sees their
it's not even about here's a or b it's
about b
sucks so much that it is going to come
and it's going to drink the the blood of
your children right i mean
that's the [ __ ] they're getting over
there right so like what strike back is
is i mean as many things as a strategic
revolution it's a tactical deployment
revolution but it's also i mean most
critically
it's a messaging revolution because it
takes
the conver like the the whole thing away
from this oh should we
mobilize the base or persuade
independence because that's a
that's a it doesn't matter what the
answer is a or b because
that's not the world we live in right
now and and it and it
readjustes the whole thing from the root
up to a
branding war right and in when you're in
that posture
you want to be putting them on defense
and the way to do that
isn't to defend yourself against crt and
p and defend the police and all this
[ __ ]
it doesn't matter if we could disappear
everybody that ever held that position
they would still brand every candidate
from the moderate moderate
all the way down as a defund the police
socialism that's what they'll do to val
demings we already know what they're
gonna do
right so like you can't escape that
label what you
can do is go on offense with them and
make them own
and and the nice thing is you don't have
to distort like no democrat wants to
defund the police but now the whole
party's ascribed to this position
yeah on the republican side the things
that we're attacking them for
things they're doing they're the real
things that everybody supports that are
you know the parties congressional
leadership are doing
and you know you don't even have to get
hyperbolic even though it sounds
hyperbolic it's just the facts right
and so you make it so that the
electorate has to choose
in south florida okay socialism
right oh boy don't give me a 300 child
care
tax credit um or military coup
right you pick south florida because i
can tell you this
down in south florida those populations
are afraid of socialism yeah
the south america but you know what else
they're afraid of right-wing
military coups because you look at south
american history
and what has destabilized stock
stabilized south america
just as much is like the republican
party has cooking right now in the lab
yeah i mean i think the complexity in
south florida i was just down there is
cuban americans don't care about you
know right-wing military involvement
they like it and they wanted to go into
cuba other being from argentina myself
and having a sense of the different the
different groups there
that's complex let me ask you this
intuitively it seems to me
that a lot of trump's 24 potential is
based on whether he can successfully
play king maker in 22
whether marjorie taylor greene gets
re-elected whether lauren bobert gets
reelected etc
is that an accurate assessment or does
that not really matter no i mean
partially david because marjorie taylor
greene and bobart
are i mean that's the thing is like it's
you know it's so hard to like have this
like encyclopedic knowledge of the
apparatus of how elections actually work
and all that matters in a race is you
know what percent of republican voters
and their left and their
indies into leaners are going to be
voting in that electorate versus
the other side so like you look at a
district like beau bart's or
uh especially greens they're not ever
getting tossed out of that seat right
uh they're drawn those districts are not
drawn in a competitive way
even from even from a republican
challenge you think that they're good
for as long as they want those seats
oh yeah they're never going to beat back
up i mean you are going to go
char no it i i mean even after
the holocaust i mean the horrible
offensive
stuff with the jewish the vaccine
patches yeah i'm telling you
marjorie taylor greening it's like
trying to go primary aoc on our side and
i know
guys like as soon as i say oh they're
not the same and they're not and they're
nothing alike okay yeah
but the one way that they are in like is
that they serve in districts that are
not drawn to be
competitive between the parties okay
yeah and so like they have these
distinctly ideological electorates that
they satisfy
um and you know so so the question is
this the you know the
the answer to your question is this like
okay you're not gonna be those two
and so you don't want to turn them into
symbolic um
you know um you know measurements uh but
it is true that if we can hold and we
beat back the
midterm fundamentals here and we keep
donald trump from being even in
contention to become speaker of the
house
because that's the plan guys yeah the
speaker of the house doesn't come
have to come it's never been true that
they've been so rude to their own
membership that they would go recruit an
outsider
yeah yeah yeah but the rules are there
and if mccarthy thinks for one second
one second that donald trump isn't he
doesn't have enough his eye
on that speakership especially since
he's banished out in
in basically that superman world where
they put the villains out in space and
they're rotating out in that space
that's where trump is
his only point to come back into the
public debate every day
and in a way that they have to cover him
they don't have a choice is that
speakership okay because
otherwise he's going to stay over at
least to some degree the media is aware
of how
like they they're culpable in his rise
and his tenure right so like they're not
going to just
open the door to him but if he breaks it
down right
so you really everything i mean they
have the
physical power the like the legal power
to not certify elections if they take
control in 2022
right um i mean i don't know anybody
watching this party
could come to the any other conclusion
and then their intel goal is to fight 24
do their best to win it and then if they
don't win it win it anyway
yeah as we've seen them uh uh claim from
2 a.m on you know november of 2020 that
also is
it's crazy to call it a strategy but
it's a tactic at least i guess i guess
we could say
uh no it's not crazy to call it a
strategy okay because this is something
that got articulated as did the
election narrative that trump the media
oh
trump speak like it was the whole
republican party's big lie
and they began to seed its antecedents
months before november of 2020 and they
put
all of this legwork in place that if so
that they could get
in tight margins in pennsylvania
wisconsin michigan
right a preventing those ballots from
arriving and getting counted until
election night ballots came
which were anticipated to
disproportionately break for trump
so that they were creating strategically
a situation on election night where
trump would be ahead in the
vote count the other ballots have been
blocked at least from
that initial night of coverage right and
then they could contest
in court now it ended up a wrinkle in
that plan
because the margins were large just
large enough in wisconsin and large
enough in pa in wisconsin and
michigan to to make that really hard and
still what did they do
they went for it right never make any
single mistake as hot messes they are
over there
the thing that they are looping us on is
strategic planning
and implementation of those plans
they're they always where
i call us walking dead zombies we're
kind of stumbling along until the next
human
sets off human activity and then we're
like oh we should go deal with that
right
they're over there like velociraptors
and they're executing it on and now we
can't afford to be
we can't afford to be aimless and so
really that strategic
um overhaul i mean we're better on
issues we're better on policy and all
the wonky
but guys like the environment that we're
in what the one thing we're not better
on
is strategy and war making and we damn
well better fix it quick
yeah a point i made earlier on on
today's podcast rachel bittikoffer
election forecaster analyst host of the
election whisperer podcast
and also the founder of strike pack
rachel always a pleasure speaking with
you
yeah and i urge everybody go to strike
packs website
see what these messaging that's brand
offensive branding messaging looks like
and if you can support us
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright so there are
some genuinely interesting books that
are
um just published and forthcoming that
are sort of telling the story of a lot
of the horrible behind the scenes things
that happened during the trump
administration
we knew we expected we predicted it was
widely stated when the trump
administration was ending
that imagine all the things we learned
during the administration
and now consider how much more we are
going to learn after the fact from
reporting and people that
are willing to talk to reporters about
it and we have two such stories today
one is about rudy giuliani which we will
get to in a moment and it relates to
the big lie about 2020 but first
here is a story about trump himself and
again
his completely authoritarian tendencies
trump said
that whoever leaked the information on
his visit to the white house bunker when
there were protests going on in
washington dc
should be quote executed executed
law and order no due process
no constitutional absolutely not listen
to this report from cnn
then president donald trump told a
number of his advisors in 2020
that whoever leaked information about
his stay in the white house bunker in
may of that year
had committed treason and should be
executed that means killed folks
for sharing details about the episode
with members of the press
according to excerpts of a new book
obtained by cnn from wall street journal
reporter michael bender
trump along with then first lady melania
trump and their son barron
were all taken to the underground bunker
for a period of time during the protests
spurred by the police killing of george
floyd trump boiled over
about the bunker story as soon as they
arrived and shouted at them to smoke out
whoever had leaked it
it was the most upset some aides had
ever seen the president whoever did that
they should be charged with treason they
should be
executed the book reads then white house
chief of staff mark meadows
repeatedly tried to calm the president
down as startled aides
avoided eye contact i'm on it we're
going to find out who did it
trump's top aide told his boss trump
remained angry over the leak for days
repeatedly asked meadows if he'd found
the leaker with his top aide becoming
obsessed
with finding the source according to the
book which noted that those who said
they'd heard the president issue that
warning
had interpreted the outburst as a sign
of a president in panic now of course
liz harrington trump's chief spokeswoman
has rejected the account in bender's
book
saying that trump never said this or
suggested it to
anyone so again trump says he's for law
and order is it law in order to smoke
out and execute a leaker no
a trump says he's for due process is it
due process to do that
it is not uh so the one interesting
thing is
this is an admission that the leaked
information is true like if
trump wasn't saying i'm furious that
someone lied about me going to the
bunker
what the report is is that trump is
furious that information came out about
it and remember that donald trump said
when he went to the bunker it was for a
so-called
inspection which never passed the sniff
test but this was trump on fox news
radio
and i said go to the church i didn't
know protesters or not nobody tells me
that they say yes sir we'll go to the
church
so we walked over the church it was very
fast i think it was very symbolic
i did hold up a bible i think that's a
good thing not a bad thing and many
religious leaders loved it take a look
at franklin graham so respected and so
many others
uh take a look at robert jeffress these
are all people you know
they thought it was a great symbol and i
thought it was a great symbol
all right daniel over to you
give us give us this okay and so uh as
as you um as we lay oh and then sorry
the actual part about the uh the bunker
as well let's get to that
uh here it is just queuing it up for
everybody
mild technical difficulties today but we
are getting to it
and getting to it very strongly i might
add let's see here
okay yeah i believe we do have are
engaging in revisionist
history we're many who love to anderson
cooper of cnn
the episcopal bishop of for washington
said she was outraged that her church
had been used as a prop and now this is
strong of liberty
the heat of the kind of led to him going
across the street for this photo op
but here is what the president said
about his time in the bunker
please it was a false report
uh i wasn't down i went down during the
day
and i was there for a tiny little short
period of time and it was much more for
an inspection there was no problem
during the day
these problems are during the night that
during the day and i go down i've gone
down
uh two or three times all for inspection
right and you go there someday you may
need it
but you go there and i went down
i looked at it it was during the day it
was not a problem
and i read about it like a big thing
there was never
he's a regular old kim jong-un just like
kim jong-un goes and inspects
you know places where corn is being
grown and things like that trump was
just inspecting the bunker and something
he does regularly
of course his own attorney general
william barr shortly thereafter said
yeah no trump had to go to the bunker
things were so bad that the secret
service recommended the president go
down to the bunker we didn't have that
in our country
uh and so the decision was made we had
to move the perimeter one more yeah so
of course uh all of the stories uh that
trump is telling are not true
but the big news is trump and his
authoritarian tendencies he wanted the
leaker executed and
it is just out of this world stuff and
really you i mean listen you know i'm
not i don't i don't want to rehabilitate
george w bush's image
but i don't think george w bush was ever
saying maybe we should
have someone who leaked something killed
of course barack obama
uh did not have those tendencies either
this this is really a unique to trump
thing so that's the new report with
trump
let's now talk about the new report
about rudy giuliani
we've been wondering who came up with
the idea
of just say you won after the 2020
election
trump going out remember about 2 2 30 in
the morning
there was no reason to think that trump
was going to be the next president of
the united states at the time we
certainly didn't know
at that point and trump said we won we
won
we now have a very specific new report
about this this is in the guardian which
says
a drunken rudy giuliani urged donald
trump
on election night to just say we won
as key states started to slip away from
trump rudy repeatedly urged the former
president to lie
according to a new book a drunken rudy
giuliani
report repeatedly urged donald trump to
just say we won on election night
election night last november according
to a new book
even as key states started to slip away
from trump
and defeat by joe biden drew near the
former mayor of new york was then acting
as trump's personal attorney
a role in which he had fueled trump's
first impeachment and would later
lead hapless attempts to prove trump's
lie that his defeat was the result of
electoral fraud
according to carol leonig and philip
rucker of the washington post both very
good reporters
authors of the forthcoming book i alone
can fix it
giuliani approached senior trump aides
early on election night at the white
house
what's happening in michigan he asked
the campaign manager bill stephen chief
of staff mark meadows and senior advisor
jason miller told him
it's too early to know giuliani said
just say we won the aides said it was
the same in pennsylvania
just say we won giuliani's grand plan
the author's report
was to just say trump won
state after state based on nothing
stephen miller and meadows thought this
argument was both incoherent and
irresponsible
hilariously they later jumped right on
board with that meadows reportedly
responded
angrily we can't do that we can't
but trump did just go declare victory
right now
giuliani reportedly told the furious
trump
you've got to go declare victory now and
as we know
at 2 am trump walked into the east room
this is
a fraud on the american public he said
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
we did win this election congratulations
sir you just won the election
trump's words gave a title to another
author in the crowded field of
trump-based reporting michael bender
his book is called frankly we did win
the election and a third
by michael wolff uh landslide provide
similar accounts of giuliani's behavior
and inebriation
at key moments guys it can't get any
more clear than this
this was something even rudy giuliani
knew was a fraud all along
they later apparently felt you know once
you're once you step into the pool
you're swimming in it and then the
hearing started
and the lawsuits and the press
conferences and everything else but
according to the reports
on election night even people who later
acquiesced
to these delusions that trump won uh
seem to be against them and so
i think we're going to continue getting
more and more information like this as
we go
but no surprise in anything that is
contained here so i don't typically read
these types of books
uh because i have so much stuff stacks
of stacks and
massive dumps of books to read but some
of these new ones i
actually am pretty curious about we have
a voicemail number and that number is
2192 david p
here's a voicemail uh that i'm getting
many versions of
asking about masks take a listen to this
hey david packman i just want to tell
you i'm a big fan of your show
sounds ominous and i use you as a
resource for
most of my day-to-day habits and i just
want to thank you for all the hard work
you do
thank you i recently have been
intrigued by the um
[Music]
kind of new new delta
variant of the kova 19 yeah uh virus
and i was wondering are you gonna be
wearing your mask again
because i think i am i think i'm gonna
be wearing my mask
full force again and i've been
vaccinated twice
by the pfizer and i was just wondering
if you
or anyone else is kind of uh
looking forward to wearing your maskian
i can't say i'm looking forward to it
but i'm expecting it the way the delta
variant is spreading and you know we all
want to think optimistically
but when you look at the case trend
right now again
it's mostly hitting on vaccinated people
but the vaccines aren't 100 effective so
even if you're vaccinated you you could
still get it although the risk is quite
low
um if you see the direction of things
right now and we know how long it takes
to develop immunity we're in mid-july
we're not that far from the start of flu
season i sort of think of the start of
flu season as september 1st even though
technically it might be a little bit
later
there is every indication that there is
going to be
significant additional masking in the
fall now
do i expect that i'll be wearing masks
in small groups of vaccinated friends
i don't i don't expect that no but do i
think that
certainly uh in indoor places i mean
listen
right now when i go to the grocery store
basically no one's wearing masks anymore
and i tend to go at times where it's not
busy
i'm not wearing my mask right now i
anticipate
probably by september 15th i will be
back to wearing my mask in grocery
stores
and um my my belief is
we're going to see a lot of more more of
that now in red states
you know it's not going to be ubiquitous
but i think parts of the country that
took this seriously to begin with are
going to take it seriously again
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we've got a lot of great stuff on
it sign up at joinpacman.com
we will speak to you momentarily on that
bonus show if you are a member
otherwise i'll see you
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman